hurry me lovelies I did it again that
stupid Jana intro that's not going to
become a thing hey I have been to
youtube nextup for the whole week it's a
week where you get to spend time at the
weight i need to be taller youtube space
london we got to do so much stuff but
what's better than me rambling about it
is showing you yeah cuz i plug to the
whole week cuz i'm pretty and blogger
not expect some super cool stuff but
maybe shaky footage right now hi guys
i'm here at YouTube space so far we've
come around and now we're looking our
channel as kind of all how we feel it's
doing and what we could improve and I
have already realized i'm making love
that's okay because you guys like get it
anyway I've met some nice people at the
moment I'm going to turn around
hey I'll keep you updated oh yeah
welcome you back about the tan today
because this week on health is never
gonna be that bad I wish I only wish now
we're going to go to uni leili clubs for
that big balance throw ukulele people to
the next couple of hours I'm tired
what's up
good morning it's day two and we're back
off to the YouTube space today we're
gonna have a talk from a top creator but
before we go and do that meet my roomie
easy naylor hi I'm doing my hair tell
them what you do on the youtubes I do
music stuff so I sing and I right son
yes we are gonna try and do a cola I'll
see you later I'm back in you to space
and then with these lovely ladies you
bearing to go I started making videos
aligned many many moons ago yes it for
the main cartoons and then come around
about two thousand six or so when I
found youtube like everyone else I jump
on board and come about 2008 I'd finally
figured it out I thought I knew what
made a good viral video I'm so short
pouching canoeing we just had a chat
from Tom Scott and great it was a pretty
cool kunis yeah really useful do you
want to introduce us oh yeah I'm Charlie
and I make videos about twice asleep so
we're good fit Huntley yeah yeah
it's the size of the source in relation
to the object you're filming sorry
equipment object basically
oh my god
you
you
hey three in the YouTube Nextup camp and
today we're going to learn some Pro
editing skills in Premiere Pro then
we're gonna get our ideas sorted for
filming tomorrow because you get to make
a film tomorrow now here in the editing
my boy and I got told how did you green
screen and stuff cause I want to use
green screen tour hopefully it's gonna
work out I'm gonna take a home by get
rid and add little drawings incorporated
into the video that and a half I can't
wait forever what that patient gun to
end things to do your can feel like
sweat Sun comes out oh my gosh it was
very accessible thanks man thanks ah
cheers guys always still record it all
right the periscope is in my blog the
periscope is in my blog this is the
first this is the first time that
happened it's all underwater yeah I feel
like I'm on the side the videos is so
cool I don't look like a total weirdo
just be a little bit yes it's happy hour
now the day is to an end and we're gonna
go out soon and have a little drink i
think but at the moment i just want to
get my script done for the filming
tomorrow i also had my personal meeting
with my partner manager we looked
through my channel it was crazy to see
the kind of content that you guys watch
and games alive well up there I thought
you guys loved my songs the games
definitely the most important anything
on this channel and I know suggested see
something we all knew anyway but
definitely gonna work on that it's been
an awesome day hey again fun yeah I'll
see you in a bit on GCSE results day
running and then just got attacked by
name and
yeah okay yeah yeah we're shooting and
we're doing green screen green screen
you'll soon see what supplies we might
not make it fast site B positive it'll
be great it's gonna be great we put in a
small sample of it now there you go
thank your camera really like I know
oddly I would always hold it with it
though what I assume was built to be
held oh I just presently i'm getting
taught how to vlog bye Lucy I am now in
the makeup room I'm gonna get my makeup
sorted for my shoot this is going to be
interesting I don't know why it's a dub
right now it's kind of like what I want
to be dressed up looking like a weird
childish Tamagotchi this is pretty much
all the makeup that I own so uh this is
gonna be interesting transformation
complete how cute do me look guys how
cute you look ridiculous
my essay can you see that line dancer
maybe everyone issuing their films at
the moment I'm just shot mine here we
have it African win they're just taking
off all the makeup please yeah it's a
bit weird but I'm helping Lucy out with
her and I have become a massive [ __ ]
which I'm not usually but it's so fun
I'm a natural 35 min wage you're my
intern I babe I'm gonna leave you to it
yeah how was the filming going get
putting on my best crypts face on I'll
be finished yet I've got a few more
things to do like Oh money money money
money
today the filming has been intense I
helped with a couple of others filming
as well I acted in some which was very
fun and I felt my own and it was great
filming in professional sets with copper
lights put the cameras I feel like a
proper little youtuber I guess it's been
mental we've just eaten a bunch of
Chinese and I am so ready for bed one
more day I don't want it to end it's
been amazing but this is good because I
can always come back to the YouTube
space which is great I'll see you
tomorrow hey guys it is the last day of
YouTube Nextup last day I can't believe
this today we're going to be editing the
videos that we were filming yesterday I
don't think I moving in mind um no
because I need to do some drawings and
stuff but I'm gonna learn as much like
hard well how to edit that green screen
and hopefully you guys should see it
soon it's gonna be a little bit odd and
then we've got some Q&A time with some
YouTube alumni the word is its Jackie
Dean and then we have our graduation
party so I just managed to do a run of
the video so that everyone here can you
see it I'm totally gonna change it for
YouTube though I'm definitely leave it
like this there was very rough cut
up to as well as opposed to use this in
my video but I did and I belong things
it's a cupcake it does kind of look like
chocolate doesn't don't eat if they
hoodie I don't mind so go in for a
screening we going pretty good morning
glitch could just die so whatever your
inspiration is right about that um
what's the problem around wave of my
Bravo oh really okay uh I don't want any
trouble thank you thank you very focused
on the community and be social
congratulations
graduates of in 2016 yourselves upon the
back yag Mannix is officially a YouTube
Nextup channel of 2016 we got picked out
of hundreds and hundreds of people
because this channel has potential and
it's different and I don't know loads of
crazy stuff and I'm just mind-blown
honestly mind it has pretty much saying
it all today really i think one of the
main reasons why we got picked is
because I tell you guys everything and
you really do help with this channel a
lot because I let you in as much as i
can and i feel that without
understanding you as the viewer yeah
this channel what what even is it
because I don't know what I'm doing I'm
just hoping that you like it and the
only way to know truly if you like it or
not is to ask you there are live streams
and periscopes I've always been open and
honest with you about the channel and I
honestly feel that's one of the reasons
why we got picked so thank you for
always being so engaged and involved
another thing I loved about the week was
I got to show off you guys cuz I got to
sit down with one people at YouTube and
they were amazed at our watch time oh
yeah we got watched the videos on hack
my necks they might not get all that
many views but the watch time apparently
it's gobsmacking because you guys will
watch the whole of my video be it five
minutes or 50 minutes so thank you for
watching and enjoying the content and
giving us that sweet watch time then
YouTube's like a big thumbs up for yay
it really helped me to look at youtube
in a different light instead of just
being a hobby it gave me an insight into
how I can make it something bigger and
better not only for myself but for you
if we can make this work we can reach
out to other people grow our community
make it
influence on other people's lives and
also help me be able to produce more
videos more content for you guys they
also got me thinking about what I wanted
this channel to be about like why have I
made yag man x that's a really good
question I guess once you get into the
swing of just making video after video
after video kind of forget to stop and
think why am I doing this again and
thinking about it this channel is
exactly what I always wanted it to be
it's a place for people to come to and
they're together in their community and
I know a lot of youtubers will say that
but I honestly feel like we are a
community because it's not just about me
I know people have gained friendships
from this Community people are helping
each other through hard times and also I
wanted to show you that you don't need
to be perfect you know me I try anything
I'll try animation I'll try to sing I'll
try and be a gamer because I enjoy it I
do things I enjoy and I might not be
that good at them I'm trying to show you
that you can do anything you want to do
as long as it makes you happy why not do
it because at the end of the day it's
your life and you just got to try it if
you're just worried about being bad
you'll never do the things that make you
happy and will never be good either
because you'll never do them you'll
always be bad does this make sense we're
gonna right now but I honestly feel like
gag my necks does that with my kooky
off-the-wall content that you never
really know what you're getting even
though it's a little bit inconsistent I
definitely need to work on that it shows
you that I'm just one person and I'm
trying multiple things and just
experimenting and doing what makes me
happy and I'm not the best but I try
anyway and if I can do it anyone can do
it you can do it to the amount of you
who come to me and say that I've
inspired you or that you're off doing
your own things or you've even started
your own channels or podcasts or live
streaming is absolutely amazing because
it just shows me that the reason why I
started this channel to inspire others
to get others involved to have a
community where people can feel happy
and together is working it's actually
working and we're getting notice for it
by YouTube themselves sorry but a really
long rant at the end it was just an
amazing week I met some awesome people
and it's just so happy to see that my
dream
is coming true and I really want to say
thank you for coming along for the ride
I could not do any of this without you
guys you're awesome and I cannot wait to
see what content we make in the future
it's gonna be so much fun guys amazin
have a lovely day or evening by thumbs
up for some some thumbs up hi guys
videos have been around for years as a
really good source of entertainment as a
way of telling narratives and stories of
getting audience system around